thomas vous avez donc suivi cette
conférence de presse que faut-il en
retenir une conférence de presse qui a
été organisée à la demande de eric
dupond moretti qui fait partie des
nouveaux avocats de julian assange en
fait c'est toute l'équipe de défense
européenne de jeunes assange qui s'est
réunie en compagnie également du père de
julian assange ainsi que l'organisation
reporters sans frontières ici donc à
paris pour cette conférence de presse
comme pour donner les dernières
nouvelles concernant cette affaire et
avec ce procès qui s'ouvre la semaine
prochaine le 24 février prochain
eric dupond moretti a d'abord pris la
parole pour remercier tous les soutiens
très nombreux exprimer
depuis le monde entier à l'égard de
julien assange pour ceux d'eric
dupond-moretti qui estime qu'il s'agit
d'une peine indignes insupportables et
contraire aux droits de l'homme il a
également raconté sa rencontre avec
julian assange c'était il ya quelques
jours dans la prison londonienne où il
est enfermé le propose d'écouter eric
dupond-moretti visiblement très inquiète
sur l'état de santé de son client
le rapporteur spécial des nations unies
sur la torture
le suisse n'y ce médecin a rencontré
julian assange le 9 mai 2019
il expliqué il écrit qu'en plus des
troubles physiques
monsieur assange montre tous les
symptômes d'une exposition prolongée à
la torture
retenez ce mot si vous voulez bien
psychologique cela inclut le stress
extrême l'anxiété chronique le
traumatisme psychologique
en novembre il est
mais que la vie de julian assange était
en danger
le 26 novembre 2019 un collectif de 60
médecins indique redouté vraiment
l'adverbe est utilisé sur la base des
éléments actuellement possible que
monsieur assange puisse mourir en prison
eric dupond moretti qui estime également
qu'il s'agit d'une procédure éminemment
politique pour rappel juhel insurge
encourt une peine allant jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison puisque aux états unis 18
chefs d'inculpation ont été retenus
contre lui eric dupond-moretti lors de
son discours lors de cette conférence de
presse a également tenu à rappeler les
révélations qui avaient permis le
travail du journaliste australien en
écoute il a permis de révéler en france
que jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande avait été espionnée
par les américains ça n'est pas rien il
a permis
révélé également que pierre moscovici et
françois baroin deux ministres français
de l'économie avait fait l'objet d'une
opération d'espionnage économique
conduite par les états unis
il a permis la diffusion d'une vidéo qui
s'appelle collatéral murder
c'est une bavure de l'armée américaine
en juillet 2007 à bagdad au cours de
laquelle 18 civils dont deux
journalistes de reuters ont été tués
lors d'un raid aérien
et puis à un point a été fait sur les
différentes démarches qui vont pouvoir
être engagée par cette équipe européenne
de défense on adore d'abord appris que
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
va être saisie notamment concernant les
conditions de détention de julian
assange est très préoccupante par des
médecins mais également donc par ses
avocats comme eric dupond-moretti que
vous avez pu entendre il ya quelques
instants
je propose d'écouter antoine veil qui
est l'autre avocat français de julian
assange qui a donné quelques
informations justement sur ces
procédures qui vont être engagées en
écoute les juristes français les
juristes européens ont quelque chose à
dire sur la façon dont il est mise en
accusation
nous réfléchissons collectivement aux
moyens juridiques qui pourraient assurer
sa protection de manière concrète et que
dans ce cadre et ça sera peut être
l'objet de vos questions nous
envisageons très concrètement de déposer
une série de demandes devant toutes les
institutions qui sont mobilisables pour
permettre une protection juridique de
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui à la nécessité
d'être protégé pour pouvoir a minima à
voir les conditions de vie acceptables
et digne et pour pouvoir se défendre de
manière efficace et de manière légale
enfin comme pour justifier le fait que
cette conférence de presse se tiennent
ici à paris outre le fait que je n a
songé à passer une partie de sa vie eric
dupond moretti a tout simplement demandé
à la france d'accorder l'asile au
lanceur d'alerté
merci thomas bonnin en direct de paris
banques